madame la députée vous m'interrogez sur
la crise sanitaire
en premier lieu vous avez raison de
souligner que nous sommes dans un moment
difficile ne l'oublions jamais le vario
au micro on nous a posé de nouveaux
problèmes à nous comme aux autres pays
d'europe j'ai eu l'occasion la semaine
dernière de faire la chronologie de ce
qui s'est passé et puis vous savez que
depuis la semaine dernière avec le
premier ministre avec le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé nous avons
reçu les organisations syndicales et les
choses loin d'empiré sont en train de
s'organiser toujours plus mieux dans la
difficulté bien sûr en france comme
ailleurs mais avec une chose que nous
réussissons en france et qui est moins
réussie ailleurs c'est la politique de
l'école ouverte et nous espérons tous
nous espérons tous évidemment en sortir
bientôt
alors il m'a pas échappé qu'il y avait
eu au delà de la taxe sur la politique
la taxe sur la personne et sur le sujet
d'éventuelles de mes vacances je
voudrais en quelques mots vous vous le
voulez dire d'abord est ce que j'avais
le droit de prendre quelques jours de
congé après cette année
est ce que est ce que il y à des
réunions ou des éléments que je devais
faire pendant cette période que je n'ai
pas fait à cause de ça
est-ce que non bien sûr et troisièmement
est ce que j'aurai les décisions
auraient été différentes si j'avais été
ailleurs non plus donc il y as je le
reconnais une symbolique il se trouve
que le lieu que j'ai choisi j'aurais dû
en choisir sans doute un autre la
symbolique je la regrette mais pour le
reste madame la députée depuis deux ans
avec la majorité avec mes équipes avec
tous les professeurs de france nous
tenons la politique de l'école ouverte
c'est cela qui est l'essentiel et nous
nous perdons pas dans l'accessoire
[Applaudissements]